-I love having you on.
I have so much --
I like the -- I thought you were
going in for a double kiss.
-I know.
I just did a single kiss.
-Yeah, but it was
a good single kiss,
but I thought you were
going for the second,
so I kind of waited
for the second.
-I kind of messed up your beard
just a little bit right there.
You might need your comb.
-Because it's fa-- Oh.
-Is it fake?
-Thank you so much.
It's fake.
-How did you grow that?
-I've been -- Spirit Halloween
opened down the street from me.
[ Jazz music plays ]
And I --
-Is there music that plays
when you comb your beard?
-No, it's just in --
-Wow.
-Wow. Yeah.
Big time. Big time, right?
No. Speaking of big time, I want
to talk to you about this.
This is giant.
I wish that I did this.
You went to the White House
just -- and saw --
-Yes.
-Was it yesterday
or two days ago?
-Friday night.
-You saw Elton John's --
-We saw Elton John.
-At the White House.
-Yes.
-How -- What was it like?
-It was crazy!
I mean, we grew up
listening to Elton John.
I'm sure you did, too.
-Of course. I love Elton John.
-So my mom called and was like,
"We're invited to the White
House. We should go back."
-But you are invited
always to the White House.
-No, we're not.
No. We're not.
[ Laughter ]
-You grew up there.
-Yeah, but you only are there
for a brief period,
and then you can't go back.
-I understand.
You can't just ring the doorbell
and be like, "I have the key."
-No, and in fact, when we
walked out, my husband goes,
"Don't you wish we were just
going upstairs to go to bed?"
-Really?
-We had to be like, "Okay.
Now time to go to the hotel."
-No. You have to leave.
You're like, "No,
we don't live here anymore."
-"It's time to go."
-Wow.
-But it was very cool to see
Elton John on the South Lawn.
And I took my little girls,
who had never been,
and they couldn't believe it.
-I have a photo.
-They were like, "Wait. What?"
-They couldn't be cuter.
Look at them here.
-They're they are.
-Come on.
-Yes.
-Stop it right now.
[ Audience awws ]
But what a great family.
But here's what I want --
I have a photo here.
But this made me laugh.
You brought this
exclusive for us.
-I sure did.
-This is taken
by President Biden.
-President Biden took a picture.
First of all,
they were so gracious.
They met us at the front gate.
-Yeah.
-You know, like, we drove in
like we used to,
and they met us there.
They were standing on the steps,
and my kids were like,
[ Gasps ]
"That's the President?!
What do we do?!"
And I'm like "You say,
'Hello, Mr. President.'"
And Mila's like,
"What if I was like,
'Hey. I'm Mila.
What's your name?'"
I'm like,
"Then you'll never come back."
-"No! Don't you --
Don't you ever do that.
Don't even joke around."
-"Then you'll never come back."
But, yeah, he was --
-But not only that,
but he took a photo.
-He was like -- There
was a portrait of my mom...
-Of course.
-...hanging on the wall.
-In the White House.
-And he said,
"Can I get a picture?"
Which is just the sweetest.
-I love this.
And here's the photo right here.
-...took the picture.
-Look at this. The pic --
The portrait not even close
to being in the shot.
[ Laughter ]
Barely.
That's your --
That's your mom's arms.
That's her arms.
Or is it her dre-- Yeah.
-I mean,
look at everybody's face.
It's also some, like --
some sort of talking.
I think --
-She's so cute. She's so cute.
Everyone's talking.
You're looking somewhere else.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm pretty sure what I said is,
"President Biden, my husband
can take the picture."
We didn't really expect
the President...
-You have to frame this.
-...to take it.
-The President took this photo.
-I know.
-You have to frame this.
-It was very gracious of him.
-And I didn't get to
see you the other night.
I know you were
at Harry Styles...
-Yes.
-...at the Garden.
-How good was it?
-He's unbelievable.
-Wait. Can I just tell you --
Jimmy, I know where you were
'cause I was right above you.
-How did --
-First of all,
people were walking by.
I was like, "Is that Olivia
Wilde? Who is sitting there?"
Because people were waving
at this one person.
And it was you!
-Yeah.
-The millennial girls
know and love you!
-Yeah, that's my fanbase.
-It must be.
[ Laughter ]
I kind of saw him.
-No, no, no.
They sat me in these seats
with, like, spotlights on me
for some reason.
-I saw it.
-I go, "Any other seat
is totally fine.
I just want to see Harry
and have a good time
and kind of just dance."
-Yeah. Your dance moves, too.
I mean, I was watching Harry
most of the time because, wow.
-Who doesn't watch Harry Styles?
-Right?
-Yeah.
-Harry Styles.
-My dance moves were a little...
-But he -- Jimmy does some major
sort of, like --
It's like Grateful Dead
meets Dad dancing.
[ Laughter ]
-What?
What are you talking about?
-You were, like, jamming out.
-Kind of jamming out?
I wasn't doing that.
-Yeah, you totally were.
-I tried -- Like a ski thing?
I was trying different --
I was trying different moves
because I was embarrassed
because I was Dad dancing.
But I was Dad dancing
before I was a dad.
That's how I dance.
-No, I know.
I Mom danced before I was a mom.
-And I'm, like, dancing,
and I go -- And all these --
-Girls. I saw it.
-They had all their phones out,
and I'm already a meme.
I go, "Alright.
This is already a disaster."
I was, like, trying to be that.
And then I'm like,
"Maybe I'll clap."
-Oh, you were doing
sort of a side clap.
-I was side clapping.
Then I --
That wasn't really working.
And then I go,
"I got to stop side clapping."
And then I just stood there,
and then I did this for a bit.
[ Laughter ]
And I go, "How creepy is that?"
I go, "I just got to stop."
And then I go,
"I'm just gonna have fun."
-Wait, but also weren't you
singing every word
to every song?
Like, at one point,
I thought to myself...
-That's so sad.
-..."If my children were here,
they would be --
they would have left."
-Yeah.
-They would have been so
humiliated because I knew --
-You can't look cool
at a concert.
-No, we're nerds.
-I love him.
I love Harry Styles.
That's why I sang
every song I knew.
I'm like -- Love it.
"Matilda."
-Oh, "Matilda" is so good.
-Don't even talk to me.
-"Matilda"!
-"Matilda" is the jam.
-"Matilda" is so good.
"Late Night Talking." Ooh.
-I was doing all of it.
-My 3-year-old son can sing
"Late Night Talking."
-He knows all the words?
-Yeah, he's like -- ♪ Talking ♪
-Does Hoda --
Does Hoda get into Harry?
-Oh, Hoda loves Harry.
-She does?
-We actually -- Harry played
on the "Today" show,
and he smells
like you think he smells.
-Yeah.
Like, you know what I mean?
-That's all I wanted to hear.
-Just like you think he smells.
-That's all we wanted to hear.
He does, right?
-Whew. Yes.
-Yeah, he's money in the bank.
-I mean, what is it
about Harry Styles?
-He's money. He's just got it.
-We can't help it.
-He's got it. He's just got
everything. He's so cool.
I want to talk to you
about your book club.
Because this is a giant deal, by
the way, buddy. Congratulations.
-Oh, thank you.
-It's a massive hit.
"Read with Jenna."
I want to say --
You do a book a month.
-Yes.
-And out of -- out of the ones
you've done, 33 have hit
"The New York Times"
Best Seller list.
-Wow. You did your homework.
-I did do my homework.
Yeah, I don't need --
-Yeah.
-I don't need this.
This is all fake.
I don't need any of this stuff.
I know who I'm talking to.
-I know. It's --
-I'm a big fan.
But congratulations.
-Well, and you kind of
have a book club, too.
We need to do a collab.
-I would do a collab.
-Do you wanna do a collab?
-I would love to do one.
I don't --
-You're starting. Right?
-We were doing summer book club.
-I think you gotta do more.
-Really?
Because here's the thing.
There are a ton of readers
out there.
-There are.
-And there's tons of authors.
Our mission is to highlight
debuting diverse authors
to give authors that haven't
always had, like,
the money behind them a platform
in the "Today" show.
-Yeah.
-And it's been awesome.
-And you've done it.
-It's awesome. It's so fun.
-You've done
what you wanted to achieve.
You've achieved a goal,
and it's continuing
to get bigger and bigger.
And I just heard that you
started a production company.
-Yes.
-What is it called?
-Well, Thousand Voices.
-Thousand Voices.
-We're almost there,
but we can tell you,
and the point is to have a ton
of different perspectives.
-yeah.
-I feel like --
-And you're going to make them
into movies?
-And television shows.
So, we have seven projects
right now...
-This is massive for people.
-...of books that I love
that hopefully some of you all
have read with us
that will one day
be on the screen
if we can get our act together.
-Congratulations.
-But it feels really good
to people.
-It's cool
that you're doing this.
And it's like, yeah, get
more people out there reading.
-Yes.
-I love it, love it, love it.
-Yes, yes.
-You're awesome, pal.
I love you.
-Thank you.
-Jenna Bush Hager, everybody.
Catch "Today with Hoda & Jenna"
weekdays on NBC.
And follow @readwithjenna
on instagram.